should I leave my full-time job to focus
on my business this is something that
every entrepreneur has to go through at
some point you've got a full-time job
you've got a steady paycheck but you're
not loving what you're doing you have a
dream to start your own business you've
maybe done it on the side and you want
to know when do I stop going my job stop
relying on the steady paycheck to go and
focus on my business full-time it's one
of the questions I got from one of my
YouTube viewers costaud I don't have
pronounced stuff but anyway great videos
keep up the good work I need some advice
is it important to quit my full-time job
to focus on the business so here's the
thing a lot of entrepreneurs when they
get started if they quit their full-time
job they soon discover how hard it is to
grow business growing a business is hard
for those of you who are already in it
or doing this full time we're slugging
it out you know how hard it is it's not
easy to start a business customers just
don't come lining up to you and even if
you think it's hard going in it's way
harder than you thought it was gonna be
every entrepreneur would tell you that
it's brutally hard it always takes
longer than you think it's gonna take
you don't get the reaction you think
you're gonna get and it just takes so
much time to get launched you take your
most conservative estimates at the
beginning you think I'm gonna I'm gonna
plan this out this is like my best case
scenario and this is the worst case
scenario you take your worst case
scenario and it's always worse than that
that's just a reality so be prepared for
it
a lot of entrepreneurs aren't prepared
and they start their business and they
go full-time and they quit their jobs
and they run out of money they run out
of time like you can only support
yourself for so long before you run out
of cash so you got to go do something
and they end up having to close down
their business and go back and get a job
you need to let time for momentum to
build and grow because it happens to so
many people where they've started it
they've invested so much into it they've
built some momentum they go back and get
their job and then people start to write
back and say are you still providing
this product to service and they have to
say no because they've closed down their
business you need to let time for
momentum to grow
the best way to do that is to keep your
job and have your business go on the
side to start ideally you have a job
that's also teaching you how to be a
better entrepreneur I hate getting the
job I'd never recommend getting a job
just for the money you get a job to
learn you get a job to learn how
something is done and gain experience so
when you go and do your own business
you're gonna have a lot more success so
whatever job you're in right now if it's
just for the cash you leave that I'd
join something where you're gonna learn
something work with a smaller company
where you can get more hands-on learn
from their success and give you
experience contacts so when you go and
do your own thing full time you're more
prepared for it when you're doing this
business on the side build it up to the
point where you have some degree of
confidence get it to the point where
you're at the point of survival you're
at the point where you're not making
tons of money you're not you're not
making it rich but you have enough money
to survive and even though leaving your
full-time job and going for your own
business might be a big pay cut it's
something that you're gonna do because
you love doing it and you have enough
money to least keep you afloat here's a
quick example from a company that were
invested in it's a salsa dancing company
it started off with beginning like no
students and slowly built up but now
they teach five to six thousand people a
year how to dance salsa is one of the
largest schools in North America to
learn how to dance salsa and the founder
when she started it she was doing it on
the side she was a part-time salsa
instructor and her full-time job was at
the Marriott and she was getting
promotions every year year of the year
of the year for six seven years in a row
and was on the fast track to become one
of the higher-ups at Marriott and she'd
find herself spending all day at her
Mariette job and then all night dancing
salsa cuz she loved it so much and being
super tired the next day going to her
word her job at the Marriott and it came
to the point where her business was
growing and it couldn't grow huge
because she wasn't investing her full
time into it but it was growing and she
had the opportunity to leave and she
looked at what her what her you know
what her opportunities were and she
thought I could go and do this sauce
thing nobody has ever built a massively
successful salsa business it's usually
run by artists who keep it small and and
don't know how to build a great business
and only I can do that I'm gonna go do
that and I'm gonna take a big pay cut
but I have enough there to survive I'm
not gonna have to worry about not eating
next week or not paying my electricity
bill
I have enough to survive and I'm gonna
choose that life and she was able to
build that up and to build a massively
successful salsa business and get
investors and getting instructors and
get her own studio that costs six
figures every year to maintain she was
able to do that because she poured
herself into a business but if she did
it too early if she just jumped at that
at the beginning and wouldn't have
worked because she would have made
mistakes she wouldn't have allowed time
for momentum to build she would have had
to run out of cash and go back and get
her job so summarize if you're getting a
job make sure you're doing it not just
for the money but to learn something
you're getting skills that will help you
longer-term with your business and to
start your business on the side and do
something every day to build it up even
if it's small every day you're taking
some kind of action to build your
business get it to the point while you
still have your job to where it's at
survival to where it's at the point
where you could leave your job to be
able to focus on your business and still
maintain a base standard of living not
luxury but you can survive you can pay
your bills and put food on the table and
from there with you investing your full
time into your company you have an
opportunity for massive growth that's my
favorite way the best way to will build
your business you could jump in
full-time it can work but the odds are
super low compared to if you start
part-time keep your job invest every day
to build your business and eventually
build a massive success belief you guys
like this video please give a thumbs up
below I loved seen those come in and
please leave a comment let me know what
you think you like this video leave a
message below I want to hear from you
and if you have a question for your
business leave it below in the comments
- I make a video response thank you so
much I'll see you soon
you